guy millière bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin nouvelles
manifestations cette nuit on vient de le
voir un embrasement dans les rues
américaines peut-il être envisageable
selon les résultats lorsqu'ils elles
attendront je pense que la petite
monsieur on peut tout à fait ça grave
pour des raison très simple c'est que il
ya eu effectivement des secondes qui
sont des fraudes massives et ses trous
dose ou deux étapes la première étape
cela été l'envoi de plus de 80 millions
de bulletins de vote
là des gens qui ne l'avaient pas
demandée sous prétexte de corinthe et
russe et je dirais que je connais
personnellement beaucoup de gens qui
rentrent chez eux
deux bulletins par contre 3 bulletins et
qui aurait pu les utiliser des gens font
des ménages et d'un état à un autre
étage ont reçu les bulletins qui leur
permettait de voter dans un état et dans
un autre état il ya le même des gens qui
sont décédés étaient reçus débuta alors
domicile et ses bulles tête est tout à
fait utilisable il est lu ensuite ce
qu'on appelle ici le balo tard estime
c'est à la récolte des bulletins dans
plusieurs états quelques déjà récolté
des bulletins qui ne sont pas signés et
les attribuer aux candidats qu'ils
veulent et donc il ya déjà eu un premier
mouvement de folie loin deuxième
mouvement de fronde le soir de
l'élection le soir de l'élection les
décomptes dans plusieurs états ont été
arrêtés dans la soirée les moments où
ils ont été arrêtés il semblait que
donald ont pas les gagner et puis
miraculeusement si je puis dire entre
guillemets des bulletins sont réapparus
un peu plus tard sans l'ensemble des
bulletins en 1638 bulletins dans le
michigan et puis des dizaines de
milliers de bulletins dans l'état de
pennsylvanie dont je dirais que tout
cela est extrêmement grave pour le
système électoral américain pour la
démocratie américaine
et je dirais que je ne sais comment ça
va se trouver ton film et si jo dan
parvenait à être élu au président entre
guillemets parce que je pense que pour
une élection doit être légitime s'il
parvenait à devenir président dans ces
conditions il serait
résident le plus illégitime de
l'histoire des états unis et une moitié
du pays considère heureux que de
l'élection et il faut lui et comment est
ce que vous expliquer cette cette froide
on parle également donald trump quelles
sont les preuves également à parce que
dans notre homme n'a pas forcément
apporté de preuves depuis le début elle
et tous les autres sont en train de
trouver une idole trop pour brouiller
des avocats des juristes dans cet état
actuellement les profs sont en train
d'être réunies dans l'état du nevada
jeudi il y à l'époque non seulement des
morts au goûter entre guillemets mais
aussi que des immigrants qui sont ce qui
est aussi totalement médiane pour le
moment dans le nevada ya plus de 3000 de
bulletins de vote qui ont été déposées
par des immigrants qui ne s'est pas
américains qui ont été découverts et je
pense qu'il y aura davantage d'éléments
qui se sont découverts pour le moment
les juristes qui travaille pour dan
altran réunissent des preuves
bon les présenté à des juges et vont
ensuite si ses juges on ne donne pas de
réponses satisfaisantes que tout était
possible parce que certains nombre de
juges fédéraux ont été nommés sur le
bâlois elles sont en fait des militants
démocrates dans ce cas là ce qu'il ira à
la consultante et je pense qu'il ya de
forte chance que ça se finisse à la cour
suprême
donc il faut que ça ne se produise plus
jamais une élection ne peut être
légitimement le les processus juridique
viennent de commencer un donald trump a
d'ailleurs twitté à ce sujet il est
d'ailleurs des fonds à ce sujet la
procédure
peut-elle avoir un impact sur la
confirmation de la victoire de joe biden
sur la situation politique dans le pays
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
exactement cette attente est semble
interminable
oui mais moi tout ce que je dirai que la
tante découle du fait qu'il ya eu ces
fraudes et du fait qu'il faut que cette
question soit réglée
je dirais que tout indiqué que donald
trump avait gagné l'élection
le soir de l'élection des comptes ont
été arrêtés dans son miraculeusement
trimestre et éthiques
des bulletins sont réapparus s'attendre
à une multiplication des bouteilles les
multitudes d'irrégularités qui se sont
produites et je dirais que tous les gens
que j'ai pu connaître ici qui ne sont
pas démocrates considèrent que
l'élection a été volé donc on est en
train de la volée il exactement puisque
aucun résultat n'a été proclamés et donc
c'est avec c'est une atmosphère
extrêmement malsaine
dès 10 heures pourtant il ya des cadres
du parti républicain qui commence à
prendre des distances avec donald trump
je pense notamment à mitt romney la fois
que géniaux également qui ne qui ne suit
plus donald trump des chaînes ont même
coupé son discours comment est-ce que
vous percevez son attitude en matière de
communication à de malheureux à donald
trump dirais que j'ai regardé la prendre
au journal et était votre journal est
sans doute à mes yeux le plus honnête de
ce que j'ai pu voir dans le contexte
français dans le contexte français on ne
dit pas toujours de tout je dirais que
mitt romney est quelqu'un qu'on appelle
ici un vrai hymne au mécanisme
c'est quelqu'un que s'éloigner des
positions du parti républicain qui n'est
pas du tout représentatif des positions
du parti républicain quant à tokyo qui
nous est très très critiquée par
beaucoup de gens ici parce que
facilement le soir de l'élection qui
nous a attribué l'arizona jo maiden
alors qu' il n'y avait que 70% des
bulletins qui avaient été décomptés en
arizona
vous avez des manifestations contre fox
news une foxnews est dénoncée au même
titre que si elle est née et 6 mn n'est
plus une chaîne d'informations dignes de
ce nom je dirais que chez moi si je mets
6,1 années cinq minutes c'est le maximum
que je peux supporter il ya des
mensonges sans arrêt et je dirais que
c'est un gros problème aussi jeu direct
pour que la démocratie fonctionne il
faut que les gens puissent voter en
connaissance de cause que vous avez des
chaînes d'information qui ne pratique tu
la formation il n'y a plus de
possibilité pour ceux qui regardent ces
jeunes de voter en connaissance
dernière question on chemine hier
quel impact selon vous ce qui s'est
passé la nuit dernière à savoir la cour
suprême un magistrat conservateur samuel
alito qui ordonne à la pennsylvanie de
mettre de côté entre guillemets les
votes arrivé après le 3 novembre de les
séparer et quel impact est ce que ça
peut avoir sachant que selon l'ancien
elle justement que vous venez de citer
dubai d'honorer 28 mille voix un peu
plus le 28 mai 28 mille voix d'avancé
je dirais que la loi au mieux les
tiennent normalement interdit de compter
des bulletins qui sont avides et au delà
de la terre que la date limite c'est le
3 novembre et leur limite de réception
des bulletins center le buteur du soir
est donc tout bulletin qui est arrivé au
delà de cette heure ne devrait pas être
décompté donc la décision de samuel à la
bouche et simplement une décision
conforme à la loi et je dirais qu'il ya
d'autres problèmes qui sont posés par
exemple dans beaucoup de bureaux de vote
dépouillés manche où on a refusé
l'entrée aux gens qui sont surveillés
sont surveillés la régularité du
dépouillement et y sont pas publiques
et je dirais que rien que cela cela
devrait faire ça a été dit par plusieurs
sénateurs républicains
rien que cela deux batteurs que tous les
bulletins qui ont été décomptés ce en
présence de gens qui peuvent surveiller
équitablement les choses devraient être
annulés merci avec lumières d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur get stones institute
et auteur de après trump point
d'interrogation aux éditions balland